border state Governors are looking to
take the expected
illegal immigration surge right to the
president's doorstep with Florida's
governor desanta saying he will bus them
to Biden's home state of Delaware well
Texas governor Abbott wants to send them
to the steps of the Capitol as he's
planning to give those people here
illegally the option to go to D.C
but it's not only Republicans who are
outraged over wiping away title 42
Democrats are as well they're joining a
bipartisan group of senators calling to
keep title 42 in place until there's a
detailed plan to stop the expected surge
this comes as morale is already low
among border patrol agents who say they
feel defeated demoralized and unwanted
Governor Abbott of Texas says he's about
to take action and he explained why
earlier on Fox
this clearly is unprecedented it's a
high volume that the United States and
States like Texas are ill-equipped to be
able to deal with and the Bible
Administration has no idea about the
chaos is stoked you think that Americans
are angry about inflation right now wait
till they see the chaos that's going to
occur on the border because of Biden's
open border policies
together
Tammy
yeah you know isn't that interesting and
that's a very good sign for this country
that we all have a similar interest in
security for our families in low crime
which affects everyone does not
discriminate the nature of what the
future may look like which is what these
immigrants are coming here for this is
what we all stand for and it's nice to
see in fact that there is some
understanding especially when you
represent border states and you feel it
every day and this is a great thing
about the founders Vision house members
are more close with the nature of what's
happening in their states get reelected
more often so they have to be responsive
and this is what it's about it's about
human rights it's about keeping all
everyone safe regardless of what country
you're from and even the nature of the
security
42 was meant to to be of course an
action based on our ability to remove
people when there's a health emergency
well we still have that pandemic yes
we're managing it here thank goodness
but what we are seeing also in Mexico
are people coming in from other
countries that we are still restricting
to some degree that then come to the
southern borders a matter of fact
there's over a thousand Ukrainian
refugees at the southern border now
because of their desperation to get into
this country so it's good news but we've
got to keep it going and we're reminded
that we are not to be uh held hostage by
bad federal policy that your local
politicians Congress members Mayors can
make a difference well and Tammy is 150
countries that's what general Jack Keane
just told me I mean this is a situation
that you couldn't stem that tide
overnight if you tried so you need to
slow it down before May 23rd when it
gets a whole lot worse guy
and it is going to get a lot worse if
title 42 is lifted it is sort of
interesting to see these Democrats all
of a sudden signing letters rushing to
Republicans to say hey let's get
together and do something about this
because I think yeah they might be
worried about the policy implications I
think they are awfully worried about the
political implications because this is
already a bad border crisis it is going
to become a disaster at the end of May
and I find this interesting Harris think
of it this way President Biden cannot be
bothered to go to the border so now the
governors of Texas and Florida are going
to bring the border to him in Washington
D.C and in Delaware we'll see if that
might change anyone's perspective and
just to put this into perspective from a
numbers vantage point this is
astonishing already in the last six
months in this current fiscal year there
have been more than a million
apprehensions at the southern border
that does not count hundreds of
thousands of godaways a million
encounters so far in the last six months
that is more people than the pop
population of Delaware the president's
home state and that's before this
message sir of this massive surge rather
after title 42 goes away as planned next
month so maybe they send some of them to
Delaware based on those numbers I I'm
not kidding actually I mean if you want
to get the president's attention he
spends north of 26 percent of his time
in Delaware
uh Kaylee two things popped today we
learned that the border patrol from the
top General needs a 531 million dollars
for the benefit of having military help
out at the border they had a ballooning
of numbers down there by about ten
thousand because they were overrun
outnumbered as I like to say
um so you've got that going on and then
you have this other thing simultaneously
going on and it is that idea that we can
overcome this we can overcome this
fentanyl is going to teach us that we
can't right we can't there's an entire
generation that is being plagued by this
awful awful drug that pours across our
Southern border and as Dan Crenshaw said
well if there's no Public Health
Emergency for kovid for title 42 there
is one for fentanyl I that's just a fact
when it could kill the entire population
of the United States and it's coming
primarily across our Southern border but
I must ask why is the White House doing
everything in its power to incentivize
illegal immigration and setting the
border on fire ahead of a midterm
election year and when they're asked you
know what are you going to do about
immigration here's what they tell axios
on the president's first day in office
he sent an immigration Bill to Congress
that invests in smart Solutions okay so
blaming Congress ahead of a midterm
election vote these guys out is
essentially what they're saying they
haven't done their job it's run by
democrats and smart Solutions I don't
think so the plan that Biden put forward
has a path to citizenship and a minimal
investment if any in border security
unlike past bipartisan bills so it's not
a solution that they put forward and you
have I don't know if we have their
pictures we can pop it up again the
seven Democrats in the Senate who are
criticizing the administration that
significant Mansion calling it
frightening look at all their pictures
here pause for a second I mean I I know
uh Kirsten Cinema in Arizona you know
some are in Border actual border states
Montana's not a border state no because
Virginia is not a border state New
Hampshire is not a border state they're
all border states now because of
fentanyl when you put illegal migrants
through an unmarked office and send them
across the country every state is a
border state and if this bill passes
they they put forward a bill to
essentially keep in place part of title
42 is the president going to veto it is
he going to veto the bill I wonder
what's it perched for that yeah Emily I
I want to ask about what happens legally
when those people start to show up in a
different place because remember this
was the government that was flying
illegal immigrants around including
children in the darkness of night and
then they got busted yeah and we had all
that family you know all that footage
what fight back will the federal
government have against Abbott and other
Governors and let me carry that ball a
little further first because it
dovetails in with that question so we've
had a lot of as you said State all
states are now border states well the
governor of Iowa pointed out you put in
the middle of the night 15 unaccompanied
young female minors in Des Moines
without alerting State authorities that
is audacious that's unconstitutional
they argue
um the Nebraska governor has argued that
18 percent of migrants encountered at
the border have tested positive for
Coronavirus he says in our communities
alone in Nebraska you have inserted over
40 000 covid positive migrants into
their communities and they say where are
the other Democratic Governors so we
know that the GOP governors keep coming
together they proposed a 10-point
immigration immigration plan for the
federal government that includes
deploying more Federal resources right
Shoring up the Border reinstating remain
in Mexico and the like but the question
remains for all of those Democratic
Governors playing paying lip service to
a secure Southern border or simply
saying oh no it's not open where are
they in this huge fight where drug
cartels make 400 million dollars a month
trafficking humans traffic
and the like over the border and to
answer your question you know I know a
lot of there are a lot of proponents
about declaring that an invasion in the
southern border that raises
constitutional issues and it's
essentially because states are not
allowed to shore up the borders in an
aggressive way using weapons in that way
unless it has been declared an invasion
and courts have ruled the Supreme Court
that it's not for the courts to decide
what makes an invasion it's another
governmental entity so we know Ukraine
clearly was invaded by Russia I think we
are hard-pressed to see that this is one
especially in the public eye coming up
to midterms I think that would be a
dangerous choice but these guys need
help and this federal government is not
delivering it Tammy we literally have 15
seconds uh your Top Line thoughts about
where we will be on May 24th the day
after title 42 goes away well we know
that Washington is not going to do the
right thing it's going to be a cataclysm
it's going to be something that not just
upends our lives As Americans but
there's going to be more sex trafficking
more drugs more violence and crime in
general because of the general chaos
that will be overwhelming that border
it's going to be awful I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis